[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es ein ganz schnelles
mittagessen und zwar mache ich noch nie
in einer spinat gorgonzola soße york
ließ das sind diese kleinen teilchen
hier
wir sind so kleine noppen aus kartoffeln
und die habe ich jetzt selbst gemacht
aber für dieses rezept könnt ihr sie
auch gerne aus dem kühlfach nehmen wobei
ihr solltet euch echt mein grundrezept
anschauen denn die sind wirklich super
einfach und auch gut zum einspringen
geeignet war konsole ist ein
schimmelkäse da wirklich super schmeckt
aber auch sehr sehr aromatisch ist und
heute habe ich ein bisschen spinat dabei
das ganze ist vegetarisch und ich werde
den murat damit überraschung ich zeig
euch mal die zutaten ich brauche dafür
zwei esslöffel olivenöl eine zwiebel 1
knoblauchzehe etwa 150 gramm baby spinat
100 milliliter gemüsebrühe dass es
meiner selbst gemachte 150 milliliter
sahne
hier habe ich 150 gramm gorgonzola etwas
chili und pfeffer salz verwende ich zwei
teelöffel zitronensaft und ein paar
wahlweise und natürlich auch 500 keys
die habe ich bereits vorbereitet und die
werden auch gleich abgekocht hier habe
ich jetzt eine pfanne relative
teflonpfanne beschichtete und da kann
ich jetzt das öl reingeben und bereits
erhitzen
ich habe es nämlich auch die zwiebel und
die knoblauchzehe bereits geschält und
in feine würfel geschnitten und die
werden jetzt im olivenöl angebraten
[Musik]
ihr mich hinter den spinat abo und
braten einfach angesetzt zusammenfällt
ich weiß dass sie sagt viel aus aber
gleich gar nicht deswegen weil ich immer
verschüttet wird ganz glücklich den kick
[Musik]
jetzt möchte ich den spinat mit der
gemüsebrühe ab die habe ich selber
angesetzt habe ich auch immer im
kühlschrank da kommt noch die sahne mit
dazu jetzt lasse ich die sauce aufkochen
und gibt dann den kopf und solar den
pfeffer und das chilipulver dazu und
dann müsst ihr einfach abschmecken ob
ihr noch salz benötigt aber oft braucht
man es gar nicht denn da gab und so
lasch wirklich sein wird sich
[Musik]
wird kann ich den herd herunter stellen
und die so sind ein bisschen einkochen
lassen bis der käse geschmolzen ist die
zwischenzeit nutze ich auch um das
salzwasser also um wasser aufzukochen
dafür ich salz hinzu und kann dann den
yuppies einfach abkochen die brauchen
etwa zwei bis drei minuten
[Musik]
nachdem kaum gebe ich die nockis jetzt
direkt in die soße so verhindert auch
dass ich leben
man schmeckt ich die so nur noch mit
etwas zitronensaft ab und dann durfte
murat zum probieren kommen
[Musik]
moral ist fertig
ein paar witze drüber
die geben dem gericht einen kranz bereit
ich glaube du magst und solange ja ich
mag auch spieler also es macht wirklich
spaß
also mit spinat fällt und ich bin gott
und solaris und gold bis das wechseln
einer sagen heute ist an und schafskäse
solar ist richtig lecker ist so wollte
ich eben seine freundin ja ist nicht
jedem gefallen aber uns stopft halt auch
gern so käser soße finde ich schon so
kann man nicht so viel essen aber genial
wenn ich würde sich ja ihr müsst auch
beim würzen aufpassen ich bin meine
gemüsebrühe mit rein ich hatte vorhin
ein esslöffel zuviel gemüsebrühe drin
ich habe einfach noch mal mit sachen ich
mag es extrem witzig ja super wirklich
kriegt das super einfaches rezept den
yuppies könnt ihr wie gesagt vorbereiten
ihr könnt auch die fertige nehmen so wie
er gerne möchte
und dann ist es wirklich so ein 15
minuten rezept was wirklich super
gelingt sicher ist und gut schmeckt
falls ihr das rezept nach machen möchte
dann schaut auf meinem blog vorbei aufs
ellis - blog.de da steht noch mal alles
ganz genau ich wünsche euch viel spaß
beim nachmachen
wir setzen uns jetzt auch mit dem team
hin und essen ich wünsche euch einen
guten appetit und vor allem und bis zum
nächsten mal
kommt jungs wissen und mädels und tor
kann
[Musik]